good evening everybody and welcome to
the scitec awards
I am your host simu Liu and I currently
do have seven leaks in my ceiling at
home so uh this is this is nice this is
luxury it's warm
it's dry
uh on an unrelated note I will be
sleeping here tonight
hope that's cool Janet just a sleeping
bag in The Godfather exhibit would be
great
thank you
um now we are in the beautiful David
Geffen theater and the theater is a
scientific and Technical achievement
unto itself it boasts a Dolby Vision
dual laser projection system with a 66
foot by 33 foot size screen and a 61
Channel sound system and the ability to
project at 60 FPS at 4K truly a
one-of-a-kind immersive experience
uh so naturally you don't have to clap
for that it's okay it's okay uh so
naturally it only makes sense that at
the scientific and Technical Awards we
will be playing videos uh 1080p off of
my laptop
which they did ask me to bring
um and I and I did that I did however
forget the HDMI cable so if anybody
has one on their person if they could
kindly just throw it up here look it's
not a huge deal but we kind of can't
play any of the packages without it so
yeah just just let me know
great I knew someone would
now as an actor my craft is to bring
characters to life and to tell stories
and the tools of this craft are
basically everything that you see here
from my face to my voice to the uh
literal pounds of makeup required to
make me look presentable on camera and
my skills in using these tools is the
art of that craft that intersection of
craft and Artistry that's where the
magic happens and it's no different for
you guys whether it's me using my
talents to do I don't know something
like this
I don't know what that was thank you
don't know why you're applauding uh or
one of you here using your talents to
make it rain on set or create a digital
texture or keep a handsome actor in
Focus while he's riding a
computer-generated Dragon uh we're all
storytellers
I use my non-existent tap dancing skills
and you use well actual technical
knowledge like math and science
and if we're honest sometimes people
take your filmmaking technology for
granted but not tonight
is all about the math and the science
which is a sentence that would actually
make my parents very happy to hear me
say
but the reality is your contributions
are what make it all work I mean after
all nobody wants to pay 17 to see me
fight a tennis ball they want to see
Sean Chi riding a freaking dragon
now we have 20 honorees tonight which
means 20 selfies that I'll have to take
and not a lot of time so uh let's get
this thing rolling